to infinity and beyond go to infinity
dummies impossible nothing about science
woody buzz and the crew have returned
here's everything you need to know
before you go
the original Toy Story is an iconic
Pixar film that introduced us to these
beloved characters Jessie but watch it
back in the first one all the toys had a
real good understanding of their place
at that time at handy's room Andy's
favorite toy was Sheriff Woody up until
his birthday when he received a Buzz
Lightyear naturally what he became
jealous of the modern spaceman action
figure Olie it sounds like a car ran
over it there was this interloper that
came in and informed the Buzz Lightyear
who didn't realize what he was you don't
get it you're Andy's toy and therefore
you got big responsibilities in the
midst of their outdoor adventure and the
to bond as they struggle to break free
from SIDS twisted house they make it
back to Andy in the nick of time before
he and his family moved to a new home oh
great you found the film ends with the
top spot in Andy's heart being taken by
a new puppy for Christmas Toy Story 2
takes place four years later the villain
this time around is al owner and founder
of Al's Toy Barn he's a toy collector
that runs off with woody at a yard sale
relationships specifically between Woody
and Buzz
is core to the Toy Story films they
build over the years and through the
films to trust each other to understand
each other to support each other
meanwhile woody learns who he is he
meets Jessie a yodeling cowgirl bullseye
of horse and stinky Pete the prospector
all characters from roundup gang a TV
puppet show made in the fifties the toys
all make it back to Andy's room in time
before he returns home he mistakes Jesse
and bullseye as new toys from his mom
fun fact the prospectors warnings about
the future of the toys come true in Toy
Story 3 you really think Andy is going
to take you to college in Toy Story 3 we
catch up with Andy and his toys just as
he's heading off to college
the remaining toys in Andy's room all
contemplate their fate as they've been
stored in his toy chests for quite some
time going in attic most folks keep your
accessories with you at all times
some have been given away in a yard sale
sadly Woody's girlfriend Bo Peep was one
of them but it looks like he catches up
with her in Toy Story 4 Andy had plans
to take woody with him to college but
his mom accidentally mistakes the box of
toys he had packed for the Attic as
trash Andy's mom brings them to a
daycare so they can be used again by new
children mrs. Potato Head also discovers
through her missing eye that was left in
Andy's room that he is indeed looking
for his toys but he escapes and ends up
with Bonnie a sweet little girl that
takes great care of her toys despite all
the fun he's having with Bonnie he still
prepares to return to Andy
when he makes it back to the school and
Bonnie's backpack and apologizes to his
friends for leaving they make an escape
plan to get back to Andy push them in
alone we're all just pressed when we
throw away
so Latoya sadly macho grabs woody into
the dumpster as the garbage truck
arrives the toys join hands as they face
their fate together right before being
rescued by the aliens and there the toys
prepare to be placed in the Attic
infinitely until woody makes a plan he
writes a note to Andy that states they
would all be well taken care of by
Bonnie
Andy takes the toys to her and realizes
that woody is in the box they've been
given to Bonnie feels like the story's
over
it wasn't until we kind of dug in and
said what's next guys we started finding
these brave little moments - to explore
and it started to build into a story
that was worth telling
it's gotta be okay they keep finding
this new kind of reality to examine in
the personas of beef Gabby Gabby woody
and Porky East bun is named toy the one
she loves the most if Bonnie had an
infused him with love put eyes on him in
a mouth and eyebrows and she gave him
life to love her and then he wakes up
and only sees himself as a sport which
it's so it's fantastic I was made for
soup salad maybe chili I am NOT a toy
it's like Woody has to project onto him
he's got to educate him as opposed to
the importance of where he stands you
have to understand how lucky you are to
belong to a child huh we need to get
back to our kid Oh Sheriff woody you
always come in to the rescue Bonnie
needs 40 buddy who needs a kids room
when you can have all of this what about
woody have we not explored yet I think
even woody in a way he doesn't know that
he's going through an existential crisis
weddy are we going to Bonnie I think
it's a very helpful message that we
learned from Bo Peep which is that she's
made a life for herself it's not an
orthodox life it's not a traditional
life and yet she's fulfilled I know the
perfect toy to help do kaboom Canada's
greatest stuntman I was not prepared for
how funny Keanu Reeves is for example
Duke doing all these poses that was his
idea one more oh yeah so now you know
and now you can go see Toy Story 4
[Music]
[Music]